a very warm welcome to all our viewers
i'm anjali from simply learn and today
i'll be taking you through a tutorial on
ansible so ansible
is currently the most trending and
popular configuration management tool
and it's used mostly under the DevOps
approach so what will you be learning
today you'll learn why you should use
ansible what exactly is ansible the
ansible architecture how ansible works
the beta's benefits of ansible
and finally we will have a demo on the
installation of Apache or the HTTP
package on a client systems will also be
hosting a very simple web page and
during this demo I'll also show you how
you can write a very simple playbook in
Yammer and your inventory file so let's
begin why should you use ansible let's
consider a scenario of an organization
where Sam is a system administrator Sam
is responsible for the company's
infrastructure a company's
infrastructure basically consists of all
its systems
this could include your web servers your
database servers the various
repositories and so on so as a system
administrator Sam needs to ensure that
all the systems are running the updated
versions of the software now when you
consider a handful of systems this seems
like a pretty simple task
Sam can simply go from system to system
and perform the configurations required
but that is not the case with an
organization is it an organization has a
very large infrastructure it could have
hundreds and thousands of systems so
here is where Sam's work gets really
difficult not only does it get tougher
Sam has to move from system to system
performing the same tasks over and over
again this makes Sam board not just that
repeating the same tasks leaves no space
for innovation and without any ideas or
innovation how does the system throw and
the worst of it all is manual labor is
prone to errors so what does Sam do well
here is where ansible comes in use with
ansible Sam can write simple codes that
are deployed on to all the systems and
configure them to the correct States so
now that we know
why we should use ansible let's look at
what exactly is answered ansible
is an IT engine that automates the
following tasks so first we have
orchestration orchestration basically
means bringing together of multiple
applications and ensuring an order in
which these are executed so for example
if you consider a webpage that you
require to post this webpage stores all
its values that it takes from the user
into a database so the first thing you
must do is ensure that the system has a
database manager and only then do you
host your webpage so this kind of an
order is very crucial to ensure that
things work right next ansible automate
configuration management so
configuration management simply means
that all the systems are maintained at a
consistent desired State are the tools
that automate configuration management
include puppet and chef and finally
ansible automates deployment deployment
simply means the deploying of
application on to your servers of
different environments so if you have to
deploy an application on 10 systems with
different environments you don't have to
manually do this anymore because ansible
automates it for you in fact and simply
can also ensure that these applications
or the code are deployed at a certain
time or after regular intervals now that
we know what exactly ansible is let's
look at an tables architecture ansible
has two main components you have the
local machine and you have your node or
the client machine so the local machine
is where the system administrator States
he or she installs ansible here and on
the other end you have your node or the
client systems so in case of ansible
there's no supporting software installed
here these are just the systems that are
required to be configured and they are
completely controlled by the local
machine at your local machine you also
have a module a module is a collection
of your configuration files and a case
of ansible these configuration files are
called play books play books are written
in Yael Yael stands for yeah mal ain't a
markup language and it is honestly the
easiest language to understand and learn
since it's so close to English we also
have the inventory the inventory is a
file where you have all your nodes
require configuration mentioned and
based on the kind of configuration they
require they are also grouped together
so later in the demo we'll have a look
at how the playbook and the invent she
is written and that will probably make
it clearer so of course a local machine
needs to communicate with the client and
how is this done this is done through
SSH SSH is your secure shell which
basically provides a protected
communication in an unprotected
environment okay so we saw the various
components of ansible
now how this ansible exactly work you
have your local machine on one end this
is where you install ansible if you've
gone through any previous material on
ansible you would have come across the
term agentless often being associated
with this tool so this is what agentless
means you're installing ansible only on
your local machine and there's no
supporting software or plug-in being
installed on your clients this means
that you have not agent on the other end
the local machine has complete control
and hence the term agentless another
term that you would come across with
ansible is push configuration so since
the local machine has complete control
here it pushes the playbooks on to the
nodes and thus it's called a push
configuration tool
now the playbooks and the inventory are
written at the local machine and the
local machine connects with the nodes
through the SSH client this step here is
optional but it's always recommended to
do so it's where the facts are collected
so facts are basically the current state
of the node now all this is collected
from the node and sent to the local
machine so when the playbook is executed
the task mentioned in the playbook is
compared against the current status of
the node and only the changes that are
required to be made further are made and
once the playbooks are executed your
nodes are configured to the desired
states so as I mentioned before ansible
is currently the most trending tool in
the market under the configuration
management umbrella so let's have a look
at the various benefits of ansible which
gives it this position well ansible is
agentless it's efficient it's flexible
simple yet important and provides
automated reporting how does it
all this let's have a look at that
agentless as I already mentioned before
you require no supporting software or
plugin installed a new node or the
client system so the master has complete
control and automatically this means
that ansible is more efficient because
now we have more space in our client and
note systems for other resources and we
can get ansible up and running real
quick Antep is also flexible so in
infrastructures prone to change very
often and ansible takes no amount of
time to adjust to these changes ansible
cannot get any simpler with your
playbooks written in a language such as
gamal which is as close to english as
you can possibly get your important
basically means that if you have a
playbook which needs to be run n number
of systems it would have the same effect
on all of these systems without any side
effect and finally we have automated
reporting so in case of ansible your
PlayBook has number of tasks and all
these tasks are named so whenever you
run or execute your playbook it gives a
report on which tasks ran successfully
which failed which clients were not
reachable and so on all this information
is very crucial when you are dealing
with a very large infrastructure and
finally we reach the most exciting part
of our tutorial the hands-on before we
move on to the actual hands-on let me
just brief you through what exactly we
will be doing so I will be hosting two
virtual boxes both sent OS seven
operating systems one would be my local
machine and other my node or the client
machine so on my local machine first
I'll install ansible will then write the
inventory and the playbook and then
simply deploy this playbook on the
client machine there's just one thing
that we need to do is that we need to
check if the configuration set we
mentioned in our playbook are made right
so we'll now begin our demo this my
Oracle VirtualBox here I have my master
system which is the local machine and
this is the client machine so let's have
a look at these two machines this my
client machine the terminals opened
right now so the client machine terminal
has a black background with white text
and the master machine terminal has a
white background with black text just so
you can differentiate between the two so
we'll start at the master
the first thing to do is we need to
install our anti bill so yum install and
spill - why is the command to do so
so this may take some time
you
yeah so ansible installed the next step
we go to a horse file so whose file here
is basically the inventory it's where
you specify all your nodes in our case
we just have one node that's the path to
your host file as you see everything
here is commented so just type in the
group for your client nodes so I'm going
to name it ants build lines and here we
need to type the IP address of a flying
machine so my client machines IP
addresses 192 point one sixty eight
point two point one two seven so before
you come to this
it's advise that you check the IP
address on your client machine the
simple command for that is if config now
once you type the IP address put a space
and here we need to mention the username
and the password for our client so I'll
be logging in as the root user so this
is the password and then the user which
is root in my case that's it now you can
save this file just clear the screen
next we move on to a playbook we need to
write the playbook
so the extension for a playbook is why
am L which stands for Yamin and as you
can see here I have already written my
playbook but I'll just explain to you
how this is done so a yam L file always
begins with three dashes this indicates
the start of your gamal file
now the first thing is you need to give
a name to the entire playbook so I have
named it sample book host is basically
where this would be executed so as we
saw earlier in our inventory
I mentioned clients group name as
ansible clients so we use the same name
here the remote user is the user you'd
be using at your client so in my case
that's route and become true is
basically to indicate that you need to
set your privileges at root so that's
called a privilege escalation now a
playbook consists of tasks so we have
here three tasks the first task I've
named it to install httpd so what we are
doing here is we are installing a httpd
package which is basically the Apache
server and we are installing the most
latest version of it
hence the state value is latest the next
task is running httpd so for the service
the name is hedge t TPD because that's
the service we need to start running and
the state is started our next task is
creating content so this is the part
where we are creating our web page so
copy because this is the file that will
be created at the client the content
will be welcome and the destination of
the file will be where w w w HTML index
dot HTML as you know this is like a
default path that we use to store all
our HTML files now as you can see here
there's quite a lot of indentation and
when it comes to yarmilla although it's
very simple to write and very easy to
read the indentation is very crucial
so the first dash here represents the
highest stage that is the name of the
playbook and all the dashes under tasks
are slightly shifted towards the right
so if you have two dashes at the same
location they basically mean that
they're siblings so the priority would
be the same so to ensure that all your
tasks are coming under the tasks label
make sure they are not directly under
name so yeah that's pretty much it so
when you write your yamin file the
language is pretty simple
very
readable indentations absolutely
necessary make sure all your spaces are
correctly placed we can now save this
file next thing we need to check if the
syntax of IML file is absolutely right
because that's very crucial so the
command to check the syntax of the Yama
file is ansible playbook the name of
your PlayBook syntax check
so we have no syntax errors which is why
the only output you receive a sample dot
yml which is the name of your PlayBook
so our playbook is ready to be executed
the command to execute the playbook is
ansible playbook and the name of your
PlayBook
so playbooks executed as you can see her
gathering facts that's where all the
facts of the north at the present state
of the note is collected and sent to the
local machine so it's basically to check
that if the configuration changes that
we are about to make is already made so
it's not made we do not have the httpd
package installed on our node so this is
the first change that's made also if
it's not installed of course it's not
running that's the second change that's
made so it's put into the running state
and a final task which is create content
is under the okie state this means that
the contents already present in the
client machine so I made it this way so
that you can only see the different
states that's present so over here we
have okay four so four things are all
fine
the facts are gathered two things are
changed and one is already present to
change some it
zero clients are unreachable and zero
tasks have failed so this is the
documentation that I was referring to
previously that answer will provide
automatically and is very useful as you
can see the next step we need to just
check on a client machine if all the
changes that we desired are me so let's
move to our client
so this my client machine so to check
this since we are installing the httpd
package and hosting a webpage the best
way to do it is open your browser
and type in localhost
so there you go your apache server is
installed and your web page is hosted so
that was very simple wasn't it if you
have any doubts about the procedure or
any other part of the tutorial please
post your doubts in the comment section
below and we'll get back to you as soon
as we see them so we have successfully
completed our demo let's quickly look at
everything that you learn today first we
had a look at why we should use ansible
what exactly is ansible we have a look
at an symbols architecture and how
ansible works we then saw the various
benefits of using ansible and finally we
had demo on installing the Apache server
on our client machine and also hosting a
very simple web page so I hope you guys
really liked this tutorial if you did
please hit the like button also
subscribe to our channel if you haven't
yet so that's all from my side today
this is anjali signing off hi there if
you like this video subscribe to the
simple learn youtube channel and click
here to watch similar videos to nerd up
and get certified click here